Hi, everyone. In this lesson, we're going to go and take a
look at a more complicated layered system using the
material function setup. And I'll walk you through what I
created. So you can have a better understanding of the
possibilities using this old school method. So let's get
started. In here, I have a more complicated material method
here using material functions, let's actually take a look at
it up close. Now we did a simple kind of layout here
where we have moss, and then we have wood, and we layered
it in such a way. So that is pretty straight up on how to get
these two work together, stacking them in such a way so
that we're using material functions in a parent material to
be able to have them on top each other. So let's go and
look at the snow one up close. This is one that I
created for Disney when it came to working with their scene.
They created a VR experience called myth VR is based on the
frozen universe. So I use this example to kind of show them how
they can create some layered materials if they needed it. So
if we go ahead and go ahead and click on the parent material
here, just gonna pull this over. And we're going to take
a look at this up close. Now you'll notice immediately what
I have here in this parent material, we're using a make
material attributes. And we're prompting unreal to say, hey,
use material attributes that I've made. And in here, we
have some pretty simple function here, we have a couple
normals for blending, raising it blended angle corrected
normals, for a little bit more believability and accuracy for
those guys coming into each other. So they don't kind of
crash into each other. We have a simple rock set up here
with some UV control. And we have some basic roughness. Now
this is where things get a little bit deeper, and
actually allowed out a bit more complexity. Let's look at
the MF snow cover that I created. So let's double click
on this. So up close automatically, we can see in
here, things get a little bit more complicated. But let me
show you what I mean. So again, we're in this material
function that was made just like we did previously. In
this material function, we're also making sure that is
exposed to library, we are creating a make attributes like
we did before in the parent material. And we just
have some simple placeholders here are the initial look we
want. You'll notice here, I do have some notes in here
for each one of these. So you know what they do. This
is used as a bridge to create a new functions and
items to layer especially in this case. So we're using this
particular one as the base material. No, this material
function allows us to have a base material set up. Down
below, you'll see here we have this node will help
create a displacement over a surface. Now, this was a
little bit older material when displacement was a little
bit easier to get to, we're going to eventually reinstate
that functionality. And we do have that for nanite objects,
it's built within the nanite properties of the model
details. But you can see there was a place where I did punch
these in here. So we can have more of that in here. You'll
see we have a normal control here with a clamp here to
keeping things within a range. And then we're using
alert used to help determine whether we want the object to
use the base material or be covered in snow. So we have
that option. And then we're using NPCs. Now you remember
this from other your other classes, NPCs and material
parameter collection. In this material parameter collection,
we can choose snow color, or snow amount in this
particular case, initially choosing what that NPC is
going to be once you drag it in. Alright, cool. So
from there, we use the multiply and then we punch
these in right into a height lerp. So if we needed to
increase the height of the snow color, it work best
this way. Now you do want to be able to control some
of your base height information, you'll notice I'm
using this as a scalar, here's an input, and you've
got to be careful for banding that may occur based on
acute angles, you just got to be careful with that. Now
I do go over that in a composition class a little
bit, how you correct that in the height. We don't go
over it in this particular class. But this
definitely something you need to look out for because
banding can occur on when things are a bit less flat
and more, more round or more thick in shape. So just
keep those things in mind, we have an inverted minus
here in case you just want to flip the normals in the
snow, that gives you the ability to do so. And at
least gives you the opportunity to be able to
control some of that with the height. And we also
have a matte material blend, separate normal color
clamp. In here we have base material, top material,
and so forth. All these are kind of in here. Now
one I want to mention out is brought in from a matte
layer function, I created the MFL material layer
function snow function here. And I went in here
and we've double click, you can see that I built
another system in here. And this is where the
complexity can happens. In here, I have an absolute
world position and a snow tiling control. And I can
choose how much snow timeline I want. This is
the banding I was talking about, you'll see
that on screen there. There's a divide, there's
a bump offset, all set up in here. And you'll see
also our normals and our input here tiling. Now if
you want to redirect nodes, you can totally do
that. I just kind of kept it so that I have
make it a little bit easier with my notes, you
can see what is doing what. So I made sure
that I isolated these and you can see here, this
one helps create an effect. So when the rock
moves, the snow shifts. So we're keeping that
world alignment in there. This one right here
is just a subsurface effect that we're plugging
in to a secondary subsurface control. And then
we can control the color from here if we wanted
to, we can make that blue ish, if we wanted
to a bit more, that is up to us. And then
again, I am breaking down the notes in here. So
things are a little bit easier. And you can see
where the direction things are going. Now you'll
notice we have two outputs, we have an output
here for our H output height. And then we
also have a regular output results here. And you
can see that if we go back to we were you'll
see there's a snow tiling. If I wanted to change
it, I can change it within this function. And
I can also do it here. So telling once I'm
telling to, and I can choose what I want for
that. All right, and all these will go to the
corresponding, you'll see the height output,
we'll go to the height texture, the end result
of that snow function will be our top material
because we know that's our top material. And
then finally, we go to the results output
here. So you can see this one takes a little
bit longer to make, just because of this snow
cover, which has a lot going on. But again, I
left it kind of a little bit of a noodle fest,
just so that I can keep my notes here a
little bit. So you can see where the
directories are going where everything's going
in place. Let's open this up a little bit
here. There you go. And keeping keeping in
mind where things are clamped, and where
things final destinations are at. So cool.
Awesome. Well, that's it with this one. In the
next video, we're going to go and take a brief
look at the mega scans way to do things. And
then in the video following, we're going to go
ahead and look at the new way to be able to
create layered materials and I think you're
going to like it. That's it.